- I'm Ragini, a director at Jubilee,
and have been making videos
here for over a year.
For those who can't tell I'm an Indian.
And in fact, was born and raised in India.
So to bring some shows back to my roots,
I flew to New Delhi
and shot a few episodes with
the help of a great crew.
Very excited to share the first
chapter of Jubilee in India.
- [Pradhyuman] When I'm
speaking to someone I'll open
up layer by layer.
- [Aakanksha] Do you really want to commit
to a lifetime of staying with someone
before you've really
discovered all the layers
of the person?
- Yeah.
- Because you know, three layers down
you might realize that, you
found one that's a deal breaker.
- When I started the process
of arranged marriage I was 25
and when I got married, I was 29
- Arranged marriage is a beautiful concept
because it just expands your horizons
to meet more potential people.
- I got arranged marriage when I was 21
and I think that was very, very young.
We parted ways because
we grew differently.
- I do agree that arrange
marriages are an entire spectrum
which also do include
marriages, which are autonomous.
And the choice is given
to the bride and groom
to say no or to say yes,
but by and large, I think
agency is non-existent.
- That set up doesn't kind of,
you know, give you the
structure or the framework
to explore the other person's values
and beliefs and priorities.
- So I had a love marriage,
but of course we grew apart,
but it also gave me a lot
of insight into my own self.
What did I want?
- I really feel it was
one of the most beautiful
relationship I've ever had.
Hi, I'm Rina, I'm a shoe
designer, a polo player
and a DJ and I'm pro arrangement.
- Hi I'm Pankhuri.
I'm 35 years old and I'm a makeup artist
and I'm pro arranged marriage.
- Hi I'm Pradhyuman.
I'm 31 years old.
I am a jewelry designer.
I'm an entrepreneur
and I was a participant
in Indian matchmaking.
I am pro arranged marriage.
- Hi, I am Aastha.
I am 22 years old.
I am an aspiring musician
and I'm also a law student
and I am anti arranged marriage.
- Hi, I'm Aakanksha
I'm 32 years old and I
work for American Express
and I'm anti arranged marriage.
- I'm Suvir.
I'm 47.
I'm an architect and a trainer
and I'm anti arranged marriage.
- [Interviewer] Arranged
marriages are an outdated concept.
If you agree, please step forward.
- We've evolved.
The societies have evolved and
there's a lot about freedom
and expressions and I want
to have those fulfillment.
So I think in today's times,
it has gone out of context.
- The aspirations, regardless
of the genders, are changing.
How do you fit into those boxes?
Those, those pigeonholes.
You cannot expect that I
changed my entire sense
of style and my personality,
the way I express myself,
just because I married you.
What the hell is so special about you?
- The gender bias is so,
it's so painfully obvious.
I would never, like,
voluntarily put myself
in a position where some
stranger can just come,
evaluate my character,
my market reputation,
put me under labels like too dark,
too thin, too fat, whatever.
And actually I was having
a discussion with my
best friend last night,
I was telling her how excited I am
to be having this conversation today.
And she told me that when she was young,
when she was seven or eight,
she herself was involved
in these potential bride
visits of her uncle.
They used to go to some like
perspective bride's house
and not even talk, just observe her.
And then in the car ride back home,
entire conversation would
almost always centered only
around her physical attributes.
Her belly was showing,
so there was some stretch marks there.
And just imagine the kind
of imprint it would have had
on a girl who's just seven.
And she says that she still
carries the insecurities
that were bred because of that.
- [Interviewer] Can we have
the disagreers come forward?
- Globally arranged marriages is just 60%.
In India its still 90%
with 1% divorce rate.
Whereas globally,
I feel like arranged
marriage is not outdated
but it's growing.
I know because I lived
in New York for 10 years
and my friends wanted their parent
to get them arranged marriage.
And these people are living,
born, brought up in New York.
So I just feel that I
think it's coming back,
much more strongly.
I mean just having this
show is a very big sign that
in this day and age, this show is shown
that even educated people
are asking their parents
because they believe that these
values are also important.
Love alone is not important.
- Okay, I have been on the
online dating apps as well.
I'm having a great
conversation with this girl.
It's going wonderful.
Wonderful.
Like soul mate kind of
conversation, right?
One day my data is off I'm in some,
no network zone, okay?
She thinks that, okay, what's happening?
There is no respond to it, like this,
this person is not interested anymore.
To continue that conversation ahead, okay?
There was a drop rate of 95%.
After a year, I was like,
listen, I can't give
so much time trying to have
this conversation with someone.
And then suddenly it goes away.
Arranged marriage really helps
because the person is
constantly obliged, okay?
That speak it through.
When I'm speaking to someone I'll open up
layer by layer
and that layering takes always some time.
And when you have a support in
terms of someone telling you
and guiding you, it works wonderfully.
- I have a question for you.
- So I want to add-
- [Aakanksha] Just a question to him.
Do you really want to commit
to a lifetime of staying with someone
before you really discovered
all the layers of the person?
Because you know, three layers down,
that you found a layer
that's a deal breaker.
- Yes, but even after a love marriage
you will find layers,
which are always opening up
- The essence I think people
have lost it over the period
of time.
It was a beautiful thing that
two unknown people were made
to meet one another through
common friends and family.
And if you liked each other,
you continued the process.
So that's the thing,
It depends on how your family
also portrays it to you.
I was never pushed to go and
meet a guy if I didn't like.
So that thing I think,
and that is very liberal.
I think the basic sense and the portrayal
of arranged marriage should not be like,
Oh no if I'm going to meet this guy,
my parents are going to tell me-
(Talking over each other)
- Since you used the word liberal,
I just want to say that historically a lot
of arranged marriages
were arranged by elders,
so that the caste status
of the families could be maintained.
- Yeah of course, that still
happens in outside Delhi.
When you cross the borders
of Delhi it still happens.
- Its more like an arranged love marriage.
- It's not the pressure
of getting married.
It's the pressure that, you know what,
the environment I'm
meeting this person for
in the first time is not a
natural environment for me.
Right?
The guy's family is there.
My family is there.
I am decked up like a doll,
which I am generally not, and-
- But you're doing it with your own wish.
- I think a sense of agency
and choices is very loosely
and it doesn't actually exist.
- I being 46, I have a lot of nieces
and nephews and I, being
a DJ or a polo player,
I come across 25 to 35 where a lot
of people want to get married.
And what I see through, these apps,
they're breaking their hearts.
They're lying, it's constant
lying, it's constant hooking up.
It's constant this is going on.
They come back, their heart is broken,
they are in depression.
But, what I'm saying is why
arranged marriage is coming
because after your heart
is broken over these apps,
once, twice, thrice,
you confide that your
parents are not going
to force you but at
least do a little check
of that person and that
family background instead
of this app where people are lying
and I have also been on that app.
So to be very honest, I'm the only one
in my family or friends to
have had arranged marriage.
My experience with the
arranged marriage is
that it was a very exciting
period, we became friends,
we got to know each other ,
our families knew each other.
The culture was similar.
- So there has been a
mix of arranged marriages
and love marriages in my
friends and my family,
most have been an arranged marriages,
and by God's grace all
of them have been doing very well.
- [Interviewer] Arranged
marriages perpetuate religious
and caste divisions.
- Obviously I talk about this whole thing
with my family members a lot also.
And I was talking about how
autonomy is so important to me
and I will only marry a
person of my own choice.
And they said that
(speaking foreign language)
What is that supposed to mean?
I mean, why do honor killings happen?
So yes, I do believe that they definitely
perpetuate caste divisions,
religious divisions.
- So my personal experience is my husband,
he's from a Sikh family.
My father-in-law ties a turban
and they go to the Gurudwara.
So my thoughts were this
only that, you know,
arranged marriage will
have you divided into caste
and, you know, have you coming
from different communities
and I will have different ways,
religious expectations and all.
But when I got married to my husband
and we had an arranged marriage,
till date, never,
they have never asked me to understand or
to start learning their language.
If the families and
everybody is liberal and open
about it you can have
inter-caste marriages,
and they are successful
- To make my stand clear, I
am pro inter-caste marriages.
If you meet the right person
at the right place at the right time.
My only thing is that
the human nature feeds
on familiarity.
Today, I'm traveling, I see an Indian.
We automatically become friends, right?
The concept of arranged marriage is
to meet the people whom
you're familiar with, right?
And in most cases, the
familiar people are people
of the same societies,
from the same caste.
So that is the reason I don't see it
as actually perpetuating religious divide.
I see it that because people are familiar,
that is when like, you know,
it's going to be easier.
- Like, I'll just say
that recently I have a lot
of younger friends in America
and their parents are also believing now,
have changed over time and said,
have introducing by
arranged, different caste.
like the Gujurati
his mother is introducing
her to a known Punjabi.
So things are changing in arranged too.
- 10 years before
I told my dad, you know,
that if I like a Muslim
girl, what's going to happen.
Like, it's like, there's no way
you know how dads are like, you know,
you should know where the whole
family is and this and that.
10 years down the line he
shows me a girl who's Muslim.
Like, you know what?
I would really love you, if you,
if you say yes to something like that.
So things change.
- I have a question for both of you,
don't you think that
these personal instances,
that you just talked about,
are coming from a place of very high level
of privilege and very disconnected
from how things actually happen in India.
- No India, so I'll tell
you, India I'll tell you.
I mean it's happening here
as he said his own example.
My, my cousins and their family,
also, we are Gujurati conservative family.
They are showing their
children now, Punjabi boys.
I mean, not Muslim yet but I'm just sayin-
- Are you open to considering
that you guys are exceptions
and this is not the norm.
- No, no.
Arranged marriages simply
getting two known people together
whom you can vouch for.
So it can be of one caste
or it can be off any other caste.
It does not matter.
- Someone I know very closely
had her marriage arranged.
So her parents were in a
hurry to get her married.
This guy was set to have a job in a bank.
Now, once they actually got married,
turned out that he didn't
really have that bank job.
He was unemployed, actually.
I think when they started running out
of funds the first thing that he did,
was he sold off his vehicle.
The next thing that he did was
he sold off his wedding ring.
When she told her parents instead
of taking the responsibility,
they said that you should just compromise,
which just made me think that,
that person wasn't there to
find the right partnership
but it was to reduce that
financial liability on the family.
- [Interviewer] Parental
support is pivotal
for a successful marriage.
- From my personal experience,
when I got married,
I had a lot of adjustment issues
with my in-laws or my husband
would not understand my agony.
So then I had to go
and call my mom and ask a lot of advice
even when I had a fall
out with my husband.
And, you know, there
were certain problems.
I, my mother always
told me that, you know,
I have your back.
You can come back to me anytime.
And she always told me that we are there
with you no matter what.
And which I think that all
parents are always there
and I feel it's very important.
- I actually agree to what you're saying.
Me and my husband,
we met through a friend and
ours is a love marriage.
And, for us, when our families
met they didn't really
like each other so much,
but his family never
had a problem with me.
And my family never
had a problem with him.
And they've been rock solid
support for me and my husband.
My father-in-law has always, you know,
built me up.
If me and my husband fight
and my father-in-law finds out about it,
he's probably going to side with me.
and my father he sees my husband
like a second son and it
makes life so much easier.
- In my opinion, it's always
a good point to, you know,
at least have your family as
the team to make a decision.
They're always going to wish well for you.
You sit down and explain
that I really love her,
I really want to be with her.
And you know, I will see
myself happy with her
and I'm sure that other people,
maybe the first time they disagree,
but over the time if
they see that you persistent, it works.
- My parents have been my best
friends since age of five,
you know, there's
nothing that I don't talk
to her even today.
You know what I mean?
If any problem would
happen I would call her up
and say mom, now this happened.
Or mom, what do I do with this?
- I'm not denying that what they're saying
but parent support is always there.
Why are you narrowing down
your parents when it comes
to your relationship?
I want to love somebody
because I love that person.
I want to raise my own family.
Unless my parents have raised me wrong,
Why will I make a decision-
No, you let me complete please, sorry.
You've not let me complete.
(laughing)
Unless I have been raised
in a wrong way, why
would I choose somebody
or be with somebody who will
not have the same values as me?
I'm going to be with my
partner for a longer time
than I have been with my
parents since I met my partner.
So I want to take care of
them for 60 more years.
So I'm thinking that then,
I'm not thinking now.
- Don't you get a little
insensitive towards your parents?
Maybe they also want
to be a part when you're choosing
your partner, maybe they-
- I'm not denying that.
- Suppose you have a rift with your spouse
and you're confused.
And you ask your parent,
would you ask your
parents for your opinion?
- Why are we placing parental judgment
on such (indistinctive)
(All talking over on another)
- One second, One second,
just one more thing
One second, one second
Also, if there is a rift between me
and my spouse that's
an amazing opportunity
for me to understand each other and grow.
My parents did have an arranged marriage
and I didn't see any issues.
We were be brought up very nicely,
there was no problems in that setup,
but today people are looking
for more freedom for more personal growth.
- Marriage is primarily about love.
- True love means when
you accept your partner
with all his flaws and how you tend to go
on in life, keeping those things together.
Because after a particular time
in life it's difficult
for people to change.
So I think love is an overall picture.
You cannot say that, no
I want a perfect partner
or I wanted a perfect wife.
No, I think what makes perfect
is like your imperfection
someone who accepts you
and that is what I believe is true love.
- Your children would probably
get married and leave.
Your friends will have their
own lives and get on with them.
The one person that you decide
to live your entire life
with, I think.
I don't think a marriage should be for
one and one thing alone
but I do think that love
should definitely be one
of those things.
- Because of an arranged marriage
and I really felt that when
I got married it was not
about love.
I mean, you can't just
love somebody when you just
meet them once or twice.
And that's why I feel it's not primarily
about love it's about being friends,
about knowing each other
and growing to each other
and I feel in arranged marriage
love grows, eventually.
So, that's what I think.
- So, I would slightly
deviate from you there
because, so you said that
arranged marriages are
about growing together and
growing into love eventually.
But, I think arranged
marriages are a huge gamble,
a much bigger gamble
than what a non arranged
marriage might be.
Cause I have friends whose parents have
had arranged marriages,
but there is no love in those marriages.
Seeing that, I just think
that when the stake is so big,
not just your own life, but your children.
I think it's a slightly bigger gamble
than I myself would be ready to take.
- I've met quite a few
people during the last couple
of years.
And when you ask a girl, right,
that what are you looking in marriage for?
First thing is like, trust.
Trust is the primary
thing, always, that trust,
and then obviously there's
love which is built
from trust and that gets started later-
- I'm gonna cut you there
and tell you about a small anecdote, okay?
My husband and I, we met
through a mutual friend
and we fell in love and we got married.
But, before that happened,
my parents introduced
me to multiple prospects
and I trusted their
assessment of this prospect.
And I said, fine.
If you think he's the right match for me,
I will go ahead, get
engaged with this person.
Twice my engagement was
called off, for silly reasons.
One guy refused to even
tell me a reason why.
He sends me a text at the end of the month
saying the month is over and so are we.
And then when we sat down as
families to talk about it,
he got physical with my father!
Is that fair?
And is that my father's fault?
Or can I say that I
refuse to trust my father
because this has happened.
So this was one, this was
the second guy, actually.
The first one my parents
found his matrimonial ad
in a newspaper.
I think two days before the
engagement we get a call
from the elder brother's wife,
and she tells us that
she's filed multiple cases
of Dowdy demands
and domestic violence
against the entire family.
How do my parents find this out?
We were fortunate we found this out.
- But then that's because
you went through a newspaper.
It was not like a common-
- [Suvir] Arranged marriage.
- Its not, it not like usually-
(talking over one another)
- [Rina] Usually an arranged marriage
happens when you know the other family.
- But this happens.
When I came to the age
of getting married the first
attempt was actually going
through the path of arranged marriages
and those experiences
were not nice at all.
The one arranged marriage
I've seen the most
closely is the one of my parents.
And it's not been the smoothest
of the marriages.
- What I came
across this process was that
people are very judgmental.
They objectify you as a commodity.
So I was body shamed,
I was rejected, but
eventually I did get married.
It was an arranged marriage
and my husband accepted me
for what I am,
who I am, irrespective of my weight,
my caste or my financial background.
- [Interviewer] I have
always wanted a big,
fat Indian wedding.
- At 20, I didn't know better.
I wasn't very exposed,
so of course I wanted
and I did have, I had like a whole week
of whatever I wanted,
you know, I mean it was.
And I, because my thought
was that I'm married once
and I want to do it all.
Of course, now my thoughts
are completely different.
And I feel what a waste of money that was
- Having a big fight wedding
having all the relatives around,
having all the festivities,
having all the Bollywood tamasha.
I always wanted to be the heroine
because that was my time to shine.
But I did keep it in mind, you know,
that we don't overspend.
And I realized also what the period
of time that, you know, we,
as girls are more fascinated
by the idea of the wedding
rather than marriage.
- I agree.
- So I can never relate
to a big fat wedding
because for me I've seen how we,
as Indians, have grown.
Earlier there were small
festivals used to be all
about togetherness, celebrating together.
That essence has gone.
In fact, I don't get to
meet my relatives for years.
Why should they drop in into my marriage?
I don't understand that.
(All Laughing)
Instead, some of my friends
and from other family people in common,
people have become so close to me
and they have some common interests
and we have a great evening.
So why should they not be involved?
- I don't like big fat Indian weddings
because they're breeding grounds
for further arranged marriages.
(Everyone laughing)
All aunties casually scanning you
and start suddenly making remarks.
I think I would rather just lay back
and stay away from all that.
- [Interviewer] I would get
a divorce if I'm unhappy
in my marriage.
- I am divorced.
So I'm living example of that,
if I'm not happy, I will,
because I really believe
that two people can grow
apart, grow differently.
And then you definitely
make a choice to be happy
and cut the chord when
it needs to be gone.
- So, I've been married for
five and a half years now,
and first three years of my
married life were way tough.
And I did reach a point where both
of us decided to get divorced.
We lived six months separately,
but things turned around
and we realized that no,
you know, we should give it another shot.
And coming from there, we realized,
what is that is going
to give us happiness?
What will make our relationship better?
So, yes, I did get into a situation,
but I did not get divorced.
We Mo- I would say crossed that bridge.
And today I am in a much happier marriage.
- I think life is about priorities, right?
And if there comes a point where giving up
on one of your priorities
literally drains the joy out
of your then you cannot
make the other person happy.
Unfortunately,
my parents don't have the
smoothest of the marriages
and it's been difficult as their child
because I can see that
my father is unhappy
and my mother is unhappy.
And, and it's not because
either of them are bad people
it's just because they've
grown in different directions.
And maybe if they had
separated they would have
been happier.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I would like to comment on that also
because I lost my mother two months back.
Unfortunately,
when my parents had a very
different marriage life
and I do believe that had
my mother taken the step
of divorcing and found her happiness
and found herself,
she would have been much more happier.
And maybe around us right now!
I believe very strongly that
if two unhappy people cannot
make a happy life together.
And to be happy with yourself.
You can only give happiness
to others, if you are at peace
with yourself, if you're happy from inside
- I think that arranged
or not arranged, like,
we all agreed at one point,
that is very important to be happy.
And I think that's the underlying fact.
Either which way in any relationship,
whichever way you find it,
whichever way you have to make it work,
just be happy.
And I think that I was so glad
that that time no one said
that happiness is
something you can discount.
- [Pradhyuman] It was nice seeing you
- [Rina] Goodbye, it was
so nice to meet you all.
- [Aakanksha] Likewise.